bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouvel épisode de pourquoi sont-ils si
uniques et aujourd'hui nous allons nous
attaquer à un personnage légendaire de
l'univers Marvel Galactus le dévoreur de
monde il est l'un des antagonistes les
plus célèbres de l'univers Marvel vous
le connaissez tous et il était grand
temps que son tour arrive dans
l'émission néanmoins étant un être
cosmique précurseur des comics de l'âge
d'argent vous allez voir que son
histoire est très singulière comme to
toujours je préfère le rappeler mais
nous ne pourrons pas parler de tous les
comics dans lequel le dévoreur de monde
est apparu car le développement du
personnage s'étale quand même sur plus
de 60 ans n'hésitez pas quant à vous à
partager en commentaire les comics liés
à Galactus que vous préférz ou qui vous
ont marqué et sur ce il est temps de se
plonger dans le récit de l'existence du
dévoreur de monde voyons ensemble
pourquoi Galactus est si
unique
[Musique]
nous sommes le 9 décembre
1965 et ce jour débute un grand
événement dans l'histoire des Quatre
Fantastiques car étant donné que notre
équipe est maintenant installée depuis
presque 4 ans depuis leur première épopé
en 61 soit le début de l'âge d'argent
des comics Stanley et Jack Kirby les
papas de Marvel Comics veulent désormais
élever la barre et nous proposer de
l'inédit quelque chose d'encore jamais
vu et pour se faire ils vont donner
naissance à un nouvel antagoniste
suprême et qui casse les code par
rapport aux autres méchants qui nous ont
été proposés jusqu'à maintenant du coup
au grands mot les grand moyen pour
introduire cette entité ils vont nous
proposer une épopée qui va se dérouler
sur plus de trois comics alors que nos
fantastiques sortent à peine d'un lourd
combat face à Maximus le frère de Black
Bolt des Inhumains le comic fait un
grand écart pour nous montrer un plan
large de l'espace là-bas nous y voyons
un être très élégant et plein de grâce
en train de voyager librement dans le
cosmos un certain Surfeur d'Argent bien
évidemment en voyant cette entité en
train de slalomer mais entre les
astéroïdes et surfant tout en légèreté à
travers l'univers on se dit que les
Quatre Fantastiques vont avoir du pain
sur la planche car il doit s'agir là de
leur nouvel antagoniste mais tout à coup
dans son périple le Surfeur d'Argent va
passer à côté de la planète des scrull
et par conséquent ces derniers vont
l'apercevoir retournement de situation
les scrull qui ont déjà été les ennemis
des Quatre Fantastiques par le passé
vont nous révéler par une scène
d'exposition que le d'argent ne doit en
aucun cas remarquer leur planète au
point qu'ils vont tout faire pour la lui
dissimuler d'après lescrull la véritable
menace planante n'est pas le Silver
Surfer mais ce qui vient après lui si le
Surfeur d'Argent passe dans les parages
et bien cela veut dire que Galactus
n'est pas très loin derrière de retour
sur Terre nos valeureux Quatre
Fantastiques vont être témoin de la
présence d'un second soleil qui grossit
de manière incessante au point de
devenir une Gigante esque honte de
flamme qui va recouvrir l'entièreté du
ciel et créer la panique générale sur
Terre en réalité nous venons de faire
face à l'explosion d'une étoile très
lointaine découlant sur une supernova le
comic jonglant désormais entre le point
de vue des Quatre Fantastiques et du
mystérieux Surfeur d'Argent nous sommes
témoins que l'entité est reliée à
l'explosion et encore plus surprenant le
surfeur va même se servir de l'onde de
choc pour se propulser encore plus loin
dans les pass ce qui vous le devinez va
le faire atterrir dans notre système
solaire et témoin de la formation de ce
dernier il suspecte qu'au moins une des
planètes environnantes correspondrait
aux besoins de Galactus sur Terre les
flammes dans le ciel semblent avoir
enfin disparu sauf que tout à coup voilà
que ce dernier est désormais recouvert
d'astéroïdes monsieur fantastique
désormais enfermé dans son labo depuis
plusieurs jours pour enquêter sur ces
drôles de phénomènes est en réalité en
train de comploter avec ouatou le
célèbre Watcher un être cosmique dont la
particularité est de surveiller et
simplement observer ce qu'il se passe
dans l'univers mais sans jamais
interférer dans l'histoire à ce moment
précis c'est un véritable choc car le
Watcher nous révèle que c'est lui qui a
protégé la terre de l'onde de flammes
créé par la supernova et c'est lui qui a
recouvert le ciel d'astéroïdees pour
apparemment cacher la terre de la vue du
Surfer d'argent ce qui veut dire que
Ouat tout vient de briser son serment
mais s'il l'a fait c'est pour une bonne
raison car le danger imminent est
beaucoup trop grand il est temps d'avoir
enfin des réponses à nos questions le
Watcher nous révèle que le Surfeur
d'Argent est l'éclaireur du puissant
Galactus un être cosmique qui draîne
entièrement les ressources des planètes
capables d'abrêter la vie au point de
l'assécher complètement et la faire
mourir par conséquent il ne peut rester
les bras croisés car d'après ces dir
dans l'univers Galactus est la seule
entité capable de surpasser les pouvoirs
de ouatou ce qui sous-entend clairement
que l'humanité ne pourra rien faire
contre cette nouvelle menace au même
moment le Surfeur d'Argent suspectant
quelque chose d'anormal avec ces drôle
de barrière d'astéroïde va finalement
passer au travers et faire la découverte
de notre planète ni une ni deux le
personnage va envoyer un signal à son
maître nos quatre fantastiques tenteront
en vain d'appréhender le Surfeur
d'argent mais il est déjà trop tard ou à
tout affirme que nos héros doivent
oublier ce protagoniste car désormais la
véritable menace est en approche un
gigantesque vaisseau d'une taille
incommensurable arrive sur Terre et
dévoile enfin le fameux Galactus
l'entité nous est présenté comme un dieu
et les Quatre Fantastiques vont très
vite se rendre compte que Galactus
diffère complète des vilains qu'ils ont
déjà pu affronter outre sa taille
gargantuesque Galactus nous prouve
directement sa supériorité dans
l'univers de par son comportement il
désigne la terre comme un monde
dérisoire il ne remarque même pas les
quatre fantastiques qui passent pour des
insectes à côté de lui il confronte le
Watcher et le met face à la violation de
son serment en lui affirmant que la mort
des êtres vivants de ce monde et plutôt
regrettable mais tout de même bien moins
importante que sa propre survie la la
planète terre contient l'énergie dont
Galactus a besoin pour vivre et cette
dernière sera consommée comme la
multitude d'autres planètes que l'être
divin a déjà ingéré les millénaires
passés pendant ce temps-là le Surfeur
d'argent qui était tombé de sa planche à
cause de la chose vient d'atterrir dans
un appartement et la propriétaire de ce
dernier ne va pas tarder à aller à sa
rencontre il s'agit d'Alicia Masters la
jeune femme atteinte de ces cités va
très vite se rendre compte au toucher
qu'elle n'est pas face à un homme comme
les autres le Surfeur d'Argent à des
années lumièr d'être un humain va
finalement se dévoiler un peu plus à la
jeune femme désormais inquiète de par la
situation que lui a expliqué le surfeur
mais détectant une certaine noblesse
ainsi qu'une grande solitude dans le
visage et les dire de l'entité Alicia
souhaite éveiller les émotions du
surfeur pour qu'il épargne l'humanité
les êtres humains comptent ils
ressentent des choses ils ont une âme un
cœur ils respirent ils ont des
sentiments peu porte l'enjeu cosmique
absolument rien ne mérite la disparition
complète de la vie sur une planète le
Surfeur d'argent aux abords très rigide
commencera finalement à ressentir une
certaine beauté dans les paroles
d'Alicia ainsi que de la pitié pour
l'humanité voire de la compassion de
retour du point de vue des Quatre
Fantastiques nos héros feront tout leur
possible pour faire perdre du temps à
Galactus qui est en train d'installer sa
machine lui permettant d'aspirer
l'énergie qui compose la vie sur Terre
le Watcher va nous révéler que ce
dernier possède un plan discrètement il
s'est entretenu avec la torche et lui a
boosté ses pouvoir dans le but qu'il
puisse voyager à travers le cosmos sous
les ordres et la bénédiction d' Watou
Johnny va voyager jusqu'au vaisseau
monde de Galactus pour trouver une arme
du nom de Ultimate nfier qui serait
capable de déjouer les intention de
l'être cosmique néanmoins ce plan a beau
être la solution parfaite pour stopper
Galactus Johnny a besoin de temps et
malheureusement les Quatre Fantastiques
commencent petit à petit à être à cour
de moyens pour distraire Galactus c'est
alors que contre toute attente le
Surfeur d'Argent va intervenir pour
confronter son maître le héros de
Galactus suite à sa rencontre avec
Alicia a retrouvé l'espoir et quelque
chose qui vaut le coup d'être sauvé et
en plus de cela le Silver Surfer nous
révèle qu'entant qu'élu de Galactus ce
dernier possède en lui une partie des
pouvoirs de l'être divin ce qui le rend
capable de s'opposer à son maître ni une
ni deux le Surfeur d'Argent va
transformer Galactus en cocon d'énergie
pure mais bien évidemment cela ne sera
pas suffisant Galactus va se libérer et
répliquera face à son héros il ne veut
pas tuer son éclaireur le Surfeur
d'Argent l'a très bien servi pendant de
nombreuses années et Galactus lui
demandera de prêter à légence une
nouvelle fois face à lui mais le surfeur
ne changera pas d'avis et alors que le
combat entre le maître et son héros bat
son plein voilà que Johnny revient
finalement de sa traversée avec le
nuullifieur et rid ira instantanément
menacer Galactus avec l'arme pour le
dissuader l'Ultimate nelfier est capable
d'anéantir une galaxie entière et
Galactus craint totalement cette
possibilité au terme de la discussion
l'être cosmique va promettre de quitter
la terre et de la laisser intacte si rid
Richards lui remet le nullifieur chose
qu'il acceptera contre aré mais fidèle à
sa parole Galactus s'en va néanmoins
suite à la rébellion du surfeur d'argent
l'être cosmique va punir son désormais
ex-héros en le condamnant à rester sur
terre l'introduction de Galactus dans
les comics est à la hauteur de son titre
on ressent clairement que Stanley et
Jack Kirby voulaient marquer le coup et
proposer quelque chose d'encore jamais
vu en fait dans les années 60 dû au
succès des re fantastique notamment les
comics Marvel sont dans une sorte de
période d'abondance beaucoup de
nouvelles histoires nous sont proposées
beaucoup de nouveaux personnages sont
introduits notamment des héros et par
conséquent bah beaucoup de nouveaux
méchants sauf que voilà au bout d'un
moment les histoires commencent petit à
petit à devenir redondantes dans le sens
où nos héros en réalité affrontent
toujours à peu près la même chose des
envahisseurs comme les scrull par
exemple ou bien des des conquérants
comme docteur Doom ou Namor Galactus qui
en premier lieu a été pensé et façonné
comme un antagoniste est né du coup pour
casser ce schéma répétitif du vilain qui
souhaite dominer le monde néanmoins le
plus intéressant dans l'analyse restera
quand même la construction et la mise en
place de la trilogie de comics dont nous
venons de parler malgré le peu d'entité
cosmique à l'époque Galactus est dépeint
comme un dieu et on le ressent très vite
dans le comics alors qu'il n'est même
pas encore apparu déjà le coup du
surfeur d'argent ce dernier est
comparable à un ange quand il arrive sur
Terre il agit comme un intermédiaire
entre les hommes et l'être divin il est
comme un messager et quand il effectuera
sa rébellion Galactus va lui retirer ses
pouvoirs et le banir sur Terre à ce
moment-là du coup il devient un ange
déchu un ange exilé du Paradis en
punition de sa désobéissance et
d'ailleurs ce concept peut-être adapté à
l'entièreté des futurs héros du dévoreur
ensuite nous avons l'intervention de
ouatu le Watcher dans les années 60 les
êtres cosmiques ça ne court pas vraiment
les rues
atu est l'un des rares à exist à ce
moment-là et cela appuie son unicité
alors quand Galactus débarque et que
Watou qui est limite comparable à un
dieu se voit obligé d'intervenir dans
l'histoire et de briser son serment pour
la première fois c'est un événement fort
pour le lecteur et qui traduit
complètement l'importance de Galactus
néanmoins le plus novateur restera quand
même les intentions de l'être cosmique
là où les anciens méchants convoitent la
terre ou l'humanité rendant donc
précieux et important ces concepts au
sein du récit Galactus lui dénigre tout
ça il est au-delà de cette avidité la
terre n'est qu'une planète abritant la
vie parmi tant d'autres ce n'est qu'une
source d'énergie à consommer comme les
centaines de milli que Galactus a déjà
mangé auparavant bref tout ça pour dire
qu'à partir de là les fans seront
conquis par Galactus avec cette trilogie
de comics et ils veulent bien évidemment
absolument le revoir mais ce n'est pas
tout à fait ce que Stanley et Jack Kirby
avaient prévu 2 ans plus tard Galactus
fera de nouveau son retour dans une
quadrilogie de comics toujours dans la
saga des Quatre Fantastiques du numéro
74 jusqu'au 77 le Surfeur d'argent était
un excellent éclaireur et Galactus
commence à le ressentir son robot le
punicheur n'est pas assez performant et
la fin cosmique de l'Être suprême est
donc difficilement comblée par
conséquent Galactus va convoquer le
sorfeur d'argent et revenir sur la terre
sauf que bien évidemment Norin rad ne
veut plus aider Galactus et en plus de
cela il ne supporte plus sa cage
planétaire du coup il va trouver comme
solution de se cacher dans le microverse
mais malheureusement à cause cause de
cette action Galactus qui ne trouve plus
son héros va commencer à s'impatienter
et ne supportant plus sa fin cosmique il
est prêt à rompre son serment de ne pas
s'en prendre à la terre cette épopée
sera une véritable course contre la
montre où nos chers fantastiques
poursuivront le sorfeur d'argent pendant
que la menace Galactus ple sur le monde
au final norinrad reviendra sur la terre
et aidera Galactus à trouver une planète
consommable pour protéger l'humanité
quelques mois plus tard le 5 novembre
968 Galactus reviendra mais cette
fois-ci dans la saga du Dieu du tonner
étant donné que Galactus est un être
cosmique qui a pour objectif de combler
sa faim en mangeant des planètes et bien
quelle entité serait intéressante à
confronter avec ce dernier igo la
planète vivante bien évidemment c'est
l'une des premières fois dans l'histoire
des comics que des êtres cosmiques vont
s'affronter et le combat sera très rude
Thor qui était sur les traces de notre
dévoreur de monde dû à la découverte
perte de la destruction d'une planète et
de tous ses habitants prendra part à la
confrontation et à la surprise générale
grâce à son marteau miolnir réussira à
blesser Galactus c'est la première fois
que nous voyons l'être cosmique
ressentir de la douleur même Galactus
est choqué de cette nouvelle sensation
et Thor va bien l'exploiter au point de
faire fuir le dévoreur de monde avant de
s'entretenir avec igo pour la suite de
ses aventures rien qu'en tr d'existence
le récit de Galactus soulève déjà des
points très intéressants tout d'abord le
personnage n'apparaît pas très souvent
mais c'est quelque chose de voulu
contrairement à certains personnages qui
ont connu des débuts difficiles car les
écrivains de chez Marvel ne savaient pas
trop quoi en faire et puis le public
n'était pas trop au rendez-vous pour ces
derniers ici c'est tout l'inverse
Galactus est un véritable succès
néanmoins Stanley et Jack Kirby ne
souhaitent pas gâcher son potentiel ils
veulent que Galactus apparaisse rarement
et que quand il soit là ce soit
l'événement et à chaque fois c'est le
cas normalement dans les comics et
encore plus à l'époque les histoires
durent à peu près bah un comic voire
deux mais avec Galactus qui est le
dévoreur de monde qui a accès à
l'entièreté du cosmos et qui du coup
s'en fiche un peu de la terre et bien du
coup quand il est là il faut que
l'histoire dure et qu'elle soit énorme
c'est pourquoi nous nous retrouvons avec
des histoires étalées sur au moins trois
com mix et autre élément intéressant
c'est que bien que dans ces histoires
Galactus soit la menace principale
planante du récit et bien il est quand
même au final rangé au second plan en
fait il symbolise la cause l'élément
perturbateur mais ça s'arrête là c'est
le cas notamment de ces deux récits avec
les quatre fantastiques où ces derniers
malgré la présence de Galactus se
retrouveront à affronter d'autres
entités durant l'histoire et tout ça
c'est hyper pertinent car un
implicitement cela traduit une première
évolution du personnage c'est que
Galactus est un méchant mais pas trop
non plus il est au-dessus de ce concept
Galactus s'apparente de plus en plus un
Dieu plutôt qu'un vilain mais voilà à
partir de maintenant ce qui va nous
intéresser c'est une nouvelle trilogie
de comics toujours dans la saga du Dieu
du tonner car ça y est nous allons enfin
avoir une première origin story vient
récemment de succomber à la folie des
guerriers une frénésie qui enrage le
personnage décuplant sa force et son
pouvoir tout ça pour sauver sa
bien-aimée SIF d'un certain protagoniste
à la peau dorée mais malheureusement
c'est quelque chose qui pousse les
guerrier d'Asgard à la sauvagerie et la
soif de sang et par conséquent Thor va
devoir subir les répercussions pour son
manque de contrôle Odin le père de Thor
et grand dirigeant d'Asgard alors très
intrigué par le mystère érieux Galactus
imposera comme punition à son fils de
retrouver l'entité cosmique afin de
découvrir ses secrets et ses origin
après quelques péripéties où Thor a
notamment affronté son frère Loki il va
finalement trouver le Dévoreur enfin
c'est plutôt Galactus qui va trouver
tort en réalité l'entité cosmique se
savait poursuivi par le dieu du tonner
et ayant assez de cette situation il va
stopper le vaisseau de Thor et l'tirer
sur une petite planète isolée pour
s'entretenir avec lui Galactus n'est pas
là pour se battre il sait la quête de
Thor et estime qu'il est légitime à
entendre son histoire néanmoins sachant
le coup de marteau facile chez le dieu
du tonner il va l'immobiliser pour que
ce dernier soit tout oui ce comic est
clairement un prétexte pour dévoiler une
origin story du dévoreur de monde il y a
bien des siècles à la naissance des
galaxies un vaisseau s'est écrasé sur
une planète où se trouvait le er témoin
de la technologie avancée apparente sur
le vaisseau et curieux d'en savoir plus
Le Watcher part à sa découverte mais la
seule trouvaille sera un équipage
complètement décimé Galactus nous
précise que lors de la scène tragique
dont le Watcher a fait face ce dernier
aurait compris que l'équipage aurait
semble-t-il été décimé par des
radiations mais que contre toute attente
parmi les morts une personne avait
survécu à l'écoute de ce récit Thor
impatient de depuis le début de
l'histoire commencera à provoquer le
dévoreur de monde du style Galactus le
seul survivant oh là là que c'est
étonnant sauf que l'être cosmique n'est
pas d'umur à rire à cette époque comme
il nous l'explique il n'était pas encore
Galactus après quelques échange l'être
divin nous dévoilera qu'il ressent une
certaine lassitude et que son cœur est
lourd tout ce que son destin lui a
apportter c'est cette horrible fin
cosmique et lorsque cette dernière est
comblée il ne lui reste que les
souvenirs d'une époque très lointaine
d'un monde merveilleux un véritable
paradis qui n'existe plus et ne
reviendra jamais ta la planète natale de
Galactus abritait possiblement la
civilisation la plus avancé sur
n'importe quel aspect et ce dans tout
l'Univers mais malheureusement un Mâ
sévissait dans le cosmos une sorte de
fléo une peste qui ravageait la vie
elle-même malgré l'immensité de l'espace
et la supériorité de Taha aucun remède
aucune solution n'existait pour contrer
ce mal inévitable comprenant donc que
leur destin était scellé les derniers
habitants de TAA dont Galactus faisait
partie ont souhaité dans un dernier élan
pour faire prospérer la gloire de leur
civilisation quitter la planète pour
mourir dans les flammes du plus grand
soleil de l'univers cependant il était
déjà trop tard la mystérieuse peste a
finalement déci l'équipage durant leur
ultime voyage tous sauf un allez savoir
pourquoi Galactus a survécu ce fléo à la
star de ses coéquipiers l'a renforcé
l'octroyant un immense nouveau pouvoir
une toute nouvelle énergie la suite vous
la connaissez le vaisseau après avoir
dérivé pendant des années s'est craché
sur la planète du Watcher finalement
Galactus va nous révéler que le Watcher
a fait face au plus grand dilemme de sa
vie car ressentant la puissance du seul
être survivant dans le vaisseau il a
finalement compris quel serait le futur
destin de cette nouvelle entité qui est
Galactus un être capable d'engloutir des
mondes avec une fin assaciable sauf
qu'avec son serment de ne jamais
intervenir dans l'histoire de l'Univers
le Watcher s'est questionné sur s'il
devait stopper cet être inconscient qui
allait causer la mort d'un nombre
incalculable d'être vivant finalement
Galactus encore instable et inconscient
s'est senti menacé et le watch n'aura
même pas eu le temps d'intervenir suite
à ce réveil surprise Galactus s'est
rendu compte qu'il était encore beaucoup
trop tôt pour lui d'émerger et pour
faciliter la maturation de sa nouvelle
existence il a façonné une armure
capable de stabiliser son pouvoir puis a
modifier son vaisseau pour en faire une
sorte d'incubateur après toutes ces
révélations Thor va intégrer que peu
importe ce qu'il se passera dans
l'univers tant que Galactus existera
aucun monde ne sera en curité armé de
son marteau le dieu du tonner est prêt à
engager le combat contre Galactus mais
voilà que contre toute attente Odin va
intervenir pour récupérer son fils lui
affirmant que sa mission est désormais
accomplie et que l'heure de Galactus
n'est pas encore arrivé à partir de ce
moment-là notre perception de Galactus
change radicalement et bien que les
mystères l' torant soit toujours aussi
grand avoir quelques trait de caractère
des sentiments et bien ça nous permet
quand même de mieux nous attacher au
personnage aussi cosmique soit-il en
vrai ce qui est intéressant avec ce
comic c'est de voir à quel point
Galactus casse les codes étant l'une des
premières véritables entités cosmiques à
faire son entrée dans l'univers Marvel
on sent que les scénaristes étaient
encore assez hésitants concernant le
rôle de ces fameux êtres cosmiques
justement ou du moins de leurs histoires
nous ne sommes toute façon après tout
qu'au balbuement des dieux de Marvel
d'ailleurs Galactus contrairement à la
plupart des antagonistes il nous raconte
lui-même sa propre histoire et c'est un
détail que j'aime beaucoup il est une
divinité il est l'être le plus ancien de
l'univers donc qui à part lui peut
connaître ses origines ou son histoire
tiens et d'ailleurs tant que j'y pense
fact qui traduit complètement qu'il ne
savait pas encore trop où all est avec
Galactus c'est sa liaison avec Thor Thor
c'est un personnage qui a toujours une
place assez particulière au sein des
Avengers surtout à leur début
contrairement à un Iron Man ou un
captaine amerriica bah oui Thor est un
Dieu il est le dieu du tonner et à ce
moment-là bah Galactus il est dépint
comme tel comme un dieu lui aussi seul
Thor a réussi à blesser Galactus parmi
les héros dans les années 60 et ce n'est
pas rien Galactus estime que Thor est
capable d'entendre son histoire car il
sait qu'il est l'un des rares à pouvoir
peut-être appréhender son existence car
il est lui aussi un Dieu même si voilà
on sait que Galactus et Thor ne jouent
pas du tout dans la même cour mais dans
les années 60 c'est encore quelque chose
d'assez flou Thor est un Dieu il vient
de l'espace donc parmi les héros
naturellement Galactus est dirigé à
atterrir dans la saga du Dieu du tonner
bref à partir d'ici je pense que nous
allons accélérer un petit peu plus la
cadence car même si les appar de
Galactus se multiplie les récits
comptant le dévoreur de monde vont
pousser le personnage à devenir de plus
en plus secondaire un peu comme nous
avons pu le voir précédemment et c'est
pour la simple et bonne raison que sa
condition d'être cosmique le démarque de
plus en plus de l'échelle que nous
proposent les comics comme évoqué
Galactus est au-delà du bien et du mal
il n'est pas ou plus véritablement un
vilain à proprement parler et sa
condition de dévoreur de monde et d'être
cosmique le place plutôt en tant que
cause du scénario en fait il devient
beaucoup trop divin scénaristiquement
suite à cela le dévreur apparaîtra dans
les comics 122 et 123 des Quatre
Fantastiques nous le verrons également
au centre d'une quadrilogie où il sera
accompagné de Thor pour confronter igo
récemment devenu fou en 74 ou encore de
nouveau dans la saga des fantasti fort
en 76 où cette fois-ci il souhaitera
consommer la fameuse contreterre du M
tre de l'évolution 3 ans après Galactus
reviendra mais cette fois-ci ce seront
les quatre fantastiques qui iront le
chercher et ce pour lui demander de
l'aide pour confronter un certain vilain
surpuissant du nom de sphinx cette
épopée aboutira d'ailleurs sur
l'émergence d'un nouvel héros principal
pour Galactus un roi tyrannique
provenant de la planète Birge qui porte
le nom de Tyros d'ailleurs nous pouvons
noter également des apparitions comme
avec l'héroïne mutante d'azler dans sa
série éponyme ou Galactus s'ira
temporairement à la jeune femme ou
encore la saga Rome oou le dévoreur de
monde tentera de consommer un système
qui finalement réussira à lui tenir tête
ce qui va nous intéresser désormais
c'est un comic très particulier comme je
vous l'ai expliqué en 69 les êtres
cosmiques ça n'existe pas vraiment ce
n'est pas vraiment quelque chose
d'encore établi et vous avez dû le
ressentir mais l'Origin story dévoilé
dans la saga de Thor n'est pas ouf on ne
comprend pas grand-chose l'histoire est
assez floue bref c'est incomplet sauf
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes désormais
dans les années 80 le monde de Marvel a
bien avancé il a bien évolué et beaucoup
de dessinateurs et écrivains du coup
sont passés par là les êtres cosmiques
sont de plus en plus introduits et
développés donc vous l'aurez compris
c'est une nouvelle ère pour Galactus ce
qui nous amène à avoir une véritable
origin story remanié en 83 via le comic
one shot super vient classic Galactus
the origin en soit l'histoire qui nous
est contée reste globalement la même que
celle des comics Thor nous redécouvrons
ta qui fait partie des civilisations les
plus avancées de l'Univers nous
retrouvons Galactus sous son ancienne
forme humaine à la différence que cette
fois-ci nous avons enfin son vrai nom
Galan et nous retrouvons bien évidemment
la chute inévitable du peuple de ta
ainsi que des autres civilisations de
l'univers néanmoins désormais nous
savons la cause de cette extinction les
molécules présentes dans l'univers sont
en train de changer et c'est
annonciateur d'une véritable catastrophe
car en réalité cela veut dire que le
cosmos est en train de s'effondrer sur
lui-même le monde de Marvel fonctionne
en cycle et reprend la théorie du Big
Crunch c'est-à-dire que l'univers depuis
le Big Bang est en constante expansion
sauf que lorsqu'il sera devenu beaucoup
trop dence il va s'effondrer sur
lui-même et à partir du chaos généré
naîtra un nouvel univers une nouvelle
Timeline lorsque Galan et son équipage
ont voulu faire jaillir une dernière
fois la gloire de leur civilisation
notre protagoniste a finalement survécu
car il a été approché par la sentiance
de l'univers
une entité incarnant le 6e cosmos il est
en gros l'éternity de l'univers en train
de s'effondrer et ce dernier va
expliquer à Galan en train de se
métamorphoser ce que je viens de vous
expliquer auparavant sauf qu'en plus de
tout ça il affirme que l'univers ne doit
pas mourir sans laisser un héritage pour
le prochain la sentiance actuellement en
train de disparaître va fusionner avec
le corps de Galan pour qu'il remplisse
un rôle bien précis dans l'univers
suivant à sa nouvelle naissance Galan
deviendra Galactus une entité cosmique
avec un pouvoir inégalable et qui doit
ravager la galaxie et pour se faire il
sera contraint de subir la célèbre fin
cosmique que vous connaissez tous après
des siècles de maturation son incubateur
finira en orbite d'une planète
inoffensive du nom d'archeopia mais
malheureusement un jour cette planète va
se faire envahir par une flotte
extraterrestre suspectant que
l'incubateur est une gigantesque arme
appartenante à archeopia les vaisseaux
envahisseurs attaqueront instantanément
l'enceinte où repose Galactus sauf que
mauvais timing l'entité cosmique est
désormais arrivé à maturation Galactus
va sortir de son incubateur et en une
fraction de seconde anilé la flotte des
envahisseurs à ce moment si on ne
connaît pas Galactus on se dit que c'est
une bonne entité qui vient de protéger
la planète adjacente de ses envahisseurs
mais bien évidemment cela ne va pas
s'arrêter là après des siècles voir des
millénaires à dormir le dieu cosmique a
désormais fa mais vraiment très fa
Galactus va donc se diriger vers la
planète la plus proche qui est bien
évidemment archéopia et il va l'épuiser
de ses ressources jusqu'à la détruire
totalement une fois terminée l'entité
repartira directement retrouver sa sa
planète d'origine ta qui n'est désormais
plus qu'une ruine finalement dans une
certaine symbolique Galan en tant que
Galactus est devenu l'héritage vivant de
ta il représente sa gloire et sa mémoire
mais en tant qu'agent de destruction et
du chaos après tout ça l'entité passera
les prochains millénaires à construire
un véritable vaisseau digne de son titre
ta 2 en tant que narrateur de sa propre
histoire Galactus finit en nous
expliquant que dans l'immensité de
l'Univers il n'existe personne d'autres
comme lui il ne ressent aucune haine
envers les êtres vivants il embrasse
simplement sa destinée il fait ce
pourquoi il existe si Galactus a pour
mission de détruire les mondes et les
civilisations c'est parce qu'un jour il
devra rendre à l'univers infiniment plus
que ce qu'il ne prendra jamais il est là
depuis la naissance de l'univers et par
conséquent il devrait être également là
à la
fin il y a vraiment je trouve une belle
poésie avec Galactus car effectivement
les êtres cosmiques ne sont pas là pour
le plaisir elles ont toutes un rôle à
jouer Galactus compris il est à la fois
l'alpha et l'oméga sa fin cosmique le
pousse à se faire craindre et détester
partout dans l'univers mais si il
accomplit tout ça c'est pour une bonne
raison et cette raison bien qu'un peu
flou encore vient de nous être partagé
néanmoins désormais c'est autour des
personnages de l'univers Marvel de
l'assimiler le 17 mars 83 sort le comic
fantastic fort numéro 257 et là-bas nous
y retrouvons un Galactus gavé de son
existence l'entité cosmique se déclare
en train de mourir car comme toujours il
doit consommer des mondes pour survivre
sauf qu'il n'en a pas envie
contrairement aux autres entités
cosmiques Galactus était un humain à
l'origine donc il y a en lui une
certaine moralité une conscience et
après plus de 20 milliards d'années à
survivre il en a assez de provoquer la
souffrance et l'annihilation juste pour
sa propre survie mais tout à coup voilà
que ça consœur la mort elle-même
intervient pour s'entretenir avec lui
l'univers est encore jeune et l'heure de
Galactus est très loin d'arriver
peut-être s'agit-il de son passé
d'humain qui l'empêche d'être lucide
mais la mort lui affirme que le rôle de
Galactus est très certainement le plus
important parmi les dieux de Marvel donc
il doit reprendre du service une fois
raisonné le dévoreur de monde va donc se
tourner vers une nouvelle planète la
planète des scrulls Galactus ce jour-là
va marquer au fer rouge l'histoire de
l'Univers et plus particulièrement de la
nation des scrull en consommant leur
monde et par conséquent détruire leur
civilisation si je vous énonce ce récit
c'est parce que cet événement va
complètement chambouler le cosmos au
point que rid Richards le leader des
Quatre Fantastiques sera traduit en
justice pour subir un procès cosmique en
fait avant que la mort vienne raisonner
Galactus ce dernier est réapparu sur
terre dans les comics 243 et 244 des
Quatre Fantastiques mais cette fois
voici contre toute attente pour la
première fois Galactus va très mal finir
au point que rid a la possibilité de lui
assainer le coup de grâce une occasion
inespérée pour l'univers d'en terminer
définitivement avec la menace planante
que symbolise Galactus sauf que rid
changera d'avis à la surprise générale
monsieur fantastique va sauver Galactus
et son raisonnement est simple il
soupçonne l'importance du dévreur de
mononde et par conséquent il va
l'épargner et le sauver mais d'un autre
point de vue vous comprenez l'ampleur du
procès si rid avait tué Galactus le
monde des scrull aurait survécu et il ne
serait d'ailleurs pas le seul l'univers
en veut donc à rid Richards et pour
condamner notre valeureux fantastique un
survivant scrull sera le premier à
passer à la barre pour témoigner de la
destruction de sa civilisation rid
Richards pour sa défense soulève la
potentielle important du rôle cosmique
attribué à Galactus effectivement il ne
sait pas quelle est la mission du
dévoreur dans l'univers néanmoins il a
compris qu'une telle entité ne causait
pas la souffrance par pur hasard
Galactus est une entité cosmique un Dieu
de l'univers Marvel donc si ces actions
sont perçues comme malfaisantes par les
habitants du cosmos à l'échelle de
l'univers elle relèv en réalité une
nécessité par la suite le dévoreur de de
monde interviendra lui-même dans le
procès pour défendre rid rich charards
qui vient récemment de le sauver assisté
par ouatu Galactus pour appuyer les
propos de rid et faire comprendre la
raison de son existence va faire appel à
l'une des entités les plus importante de
Marvel supérieure au dévoreur de monde
lui-même Eternity l'incarnation de
l'univers est invoqué en tant qu'entité
suprême etterernity va communiqué
directement dans le cœur et l'esprit des
gens et tentera de leur faire comprendre
l'importance de Galactus en vain en vain
car l'esprit humain ou de n'importe quel
être vivant est incapable de concevoir
autant de vérités cosmiques tout ce
qu'éterernity peut faire c'est au final
apaiser la population en leur laissant
la vague sensation que l'existence de
Galactus est normale et nécessaire ou à
tout le Watcher qui sert très souvent de
narrateur pour les lecteurs de comics
vulgarisera dans le prologue que
Galactus est finalement une victime dans
tout l'Univers il est en réalité le seul
être à être privé de libre arbitre car
il dépend de sa mission et de sa fin
cosmique Galactus va continuer de tester
les mondes jusqu'au jour où un monde
suffisamment évolué sera assez puissant
pour le stopper et arrêter sa fin
cosmique ce jour-là Galactus mourra et
l'univers sera en deuil un détail
intéressant de cette histoire c'est que
l'écrivain de ce comic John ben s'est
auto inclu dans le récit et cela va
appuyer le côté cosmique et incompris de
Galactus en fait souvent cela arri que
les écrivains s'invitent dans leurs
histoires et généralement c'est pour
jouer les modérateurs afin de changer le
scénario comme bon leur souhaite mais
ici John bene se minimise et se se
réduit à l'état de simple humain qui
prend des notes suite à la demande du
Watcher car que ce soit les héros ou
lui-même l'écrivain du comic personne ne
peut concevoir l'importance de Galactus
ainsi que sa longévité et l'étendue de
sa mission ce qui divinise par
conséquent encore plus l'être cosmique
malgré la facilité scénaristique bien
évidemment enfin même si Galactus a
continué par la suite à apparaître dans
une enqué de comics et a même réussi à
briller par moment avec de belles
histoires je pense notamment à la série
Galactus le Dévoreur qui aboutit
justement sur une certaine mort du
personnage ou bien même le volume 3 de
la série du surfeur d'argent qui met pas
mal notre dévoreur cosmique au premier
plan sans oublier évidemment la saga
annihilation j'estime qu'il est temps de
conclure cette vidéo avec une histoire
qui je trouve a elle aussi toute son
importance
c'est l'arc Forever bon pour vous mettre
dans le bain c'est le 50e anniversaire
de l'existence de l'équipe des Quatre
Fantastiques et pour fêter ça avec plus
de 600 comics principaux Marvel va nous
pondre une gigantesque histoire
réunissant énormément de protagonistes
et concepts qui sont apparus tout le
long de leur saga évidemment pour mettre
en œuvre tout ça quoi de mieux qu'une
guerre ultra cosmique pour unir le tout
néanmoins bien que la bataille soit
tente et bien ce n'est pas réellement
sur celle-ci que nous devons nous
attarder en réalité ce qui nous
intéresse c'est l'origine et la fin de
l'affrontement car tout ce chaos résulte
à la base d'une combinaison de choix au
premier abord à noodin et par conséquent
dans ce contexte de multivers que vous
connaissez bien il faut appréhender la
source pour pouvoir modifier le futur et
donc le cours de l'Histoire les Mad
celestiols sont là autoconvaincus d'être
des les entités au-delà du divin les
Célestes dis fou veulent conquérir le
multiver dans sa totalité et à cause
d'un pont multiversel toujours relié à
la réalité 616 ils ont pu apparaître
dans notre univers Galactus le dévoreur
de monde désormais allié aux Quatre
Fantastiques est ici présenté comme le
seul rempart de la réalité 616 le seul
étant préparé et ayant le pouvoir de
contrer les mat céestiols et c'est en un
contre qu que le dévoreur de monde part
affronter ses entités malveillantes mais
malheureusement face au nombre l'être
divin est vaincu et sa dépouille ira
s'écraser sur la terre la situation est
désastreuse Galactus des fait les Quatre
Fantastiques symbolisent donc désormais
les derniers boucliers face à
l'annihélation totale de leur réalité et
vous vous en doutez mais si Galactus n'a
pas pu vaincre les Célestes et bien
c'est peine perdu pour les quatre
fantastiques qui sont au bord de
l'effondrement néanmoins c'est quand
l'espoir semble totalement perdu qu'il
revient de plus belle avec l'arrivée
soudaine d'un Franklin et une valerriia
Richards du futur les enfant de Monsieur
fantastique et la femme invisible
Susanne Storm et ces derniers vont
repousser temporairement les M
celestials le père de rid d'ailleurs
Nathaniel Richards le célèbre voyageur
temporel est également présent et à la
grande surprise de son fils les trois
personnages ont bien préparé la bataille
ils sont décidés à changer
définitivement ce moment pour créer un
futur bien meilleur les mat celestiols
reviennent plus en colère que jamais et
Franklin Richards déterminé par
affronter seul les Titans Nathaniel le
père de rid durant la bataille sera
finalement celui qui va pouvoir nous
apporter des réponses cette journée il
l'a déjà vécu des centaines de fois et
malheureusement elle n'a jamais changé
c'est le jour où les péchés de son fils
donnent corps à des conséquences c'est
le jour où Reid richardles le père de
Franklin meurt Reid à la base fait
partie du conseil interdimensionnel des
rid Richards et le jour où il a
rencontré ses variants sa vie ainsi que
l'histoire du multivers vont changer à
tout jamais à partir du moment où Reid
va traverser le pont multiversel lui
permettant de retrouver et ses autres
lui-même il va dédier sa vie à la
protection du multivver et de
l'existence avec l'aide de ses
semblables ils vont créer d'innombrables
machines pousser la science à son
paroxisme donner naissance à des soleils
sauver des réalité et j'en passaer des
meilleurs sauf que de l'autre côté c'est
aussi ce qui va provoquer leur propre
perte et à terme causer le chaos leurs
travaux que dis-je leurs exploits vont
finalement attirer l'attention des
celestials et à cause des outils mis en
place par les rides ces derniers vont
pouvoir traverser le multivers en
revanche contrairement à ces autres
variants qui ont fait le choix de dédier
leur ristence au conseil et la
protection du multiver notre rid
Richards celui de la terre 616 a fait le
choix de revenir dans sa réalité pour
privilégier sa famille et vous
n'imaginez pas à quel point cela va
changer l'histoire si rid a le pouvoir
de ger le multivver et bien ce n'est pas
grâce à la science ou aux inventions
mais grâce à son rôle de père la
véritable et unique œuvre de ride
capable de protéger la vie et
l'existence c'est finalement son propre
fils Franklin Richards est doté d'un
pouvoir inégalé dans le multivers et
dans une manœuvre ultime pour nous
démontrer son unicité et vaincre les MS
celestials il va se servir du corps de
Galactus en le ressuscitant et en faire
son héros grâce à son action Franklin
vient finalement de sauuver la réalité
mais plus que ça encore il vient
d'atteindre le véritable but de sa quête
permettre au jeune Franklin Richards
d'avoir un père pour l'aimer et le
guider dans sa vie le calme revenu nous
sommes par la suite témoin d'un moment
intime partagé entre le dévoreur de
monde et Franklin Richards pour la
première fois Galactus nous livre sa
plus grande peur celle de vivre la fin
des temps et la mort du multivers tout
seul sauf qu'il réalise que ce n'est
désormais plus le cas si il est le
dévoreur de monde Franklin via son
pouvoir de création et quant à lui
désigné comme le forgeur de monde et
tous deux se font la promesse de se
retrouver à la fin de
[Musique]
tout
Galactus dans un calme apaisant demande
si Franklin est prêt bien évidemment il
ne l'est pas nous sommes à la fin des
temps le monde tel qu'on connaît
n'existe plus l'espace n'est désorma
plus qu'un néant la vie s'est éteinte
l'univers arrive à son point final et
comme promis Galan et Franklin sont les
dernières entités existantes le terme de
l'univers approchant Galactus est fin
prêt à remplir son ultime mission il est
disposé à mourir et laisser son énergie
vitale la seule restante dans tout
l'Univers a donneré naissance au
prochain la future nouvelle maison de
Franklin Richards cependant l'héritier
des Richards est sentimental il ne veut
pas que l'histoire soit oublié sa
famille Galactus les aventures les héros
et dans un dernier élan glorieux il va
demander à Galan de lui rappeler
l'épopée de l'univers Marvel l'univers
616 depuis l'au des temps Galactus face
à Franklin va tout lui raconter tout ce
que l'on a connu dans les comics sera
évoqué depuis la création mais au fur et
à mesure que l'histoire avance le
physique de Galan s'amooindrit la mort
de de l'univers est imminente finalement
ne devenant qu'une source d'énergie car
la fin et à la fois la naissance d'un
univers est en train de se produire
Galactus va nous révéler que sa
véritable mission la raison de son
existence c'est d'être un passeur
provenant du précédent univers à celui
que l'on a connu Galan en tant que
Galactus a permis à l'énergie qui lui a
été octroyée de donner naissance à un
nouvel univers mais aujourd'hui un autre
va devoir endosser ce rôle Galactus
n'est aujourd'hui plus le passeur mais
l'énergie à faire passer dans ces
derniers instants Galan va transmettre
son casque à Franklin qui a désormais la
charge de devenir le nouveau passeur le
nouveau Galactus du prochain univers et
tout comme Galan à son époque avec la
civilisation de TAA Fran dans le
prochain univers deviendra l'héritage
vivant de l'univers précédent à lui de
s'inspirer et de se souvenir de
l'histoire qu'il a vécu l'histoire du
monde de
[Musique]
Marvel si j'ai décidé de terminer avec
ce comic peu particulier qui sert juste
à la base à résumer tout ce que Marvel a
produit depuis le début et bien c'est
pour enfin véritablement comprendre
l'utilité de Galactus dans l'univers des
comics malgré son iconicité malgré la
légende qu'il représente dans la tête
des gens le dévoreur de monde possède un
développement aussi complexe que son
histoire le laisse sous-entendre et il y
a un comic ce qui démontre parfaitement
ça c'est le comic 262 des Quatre
Fantastiques où justement rid Richards
est jugé pour avoir sauvé Galactus ce
que vous devez savoir c'est que ce comic
a connu une controverse et pour cause
comme beaucoup de personnages de comics
l'histoire de Galactus s'étale sur
presque plus de 60 ans donc nombreux ont
été les dessinateurs et les écrivains à
représenter Galactus à le faire évoluer
néanmoins tout en restant fidèle à ses
origines et justement il est là le
problème en 1965 les êtres cosmiques ça
n'existait pas vraiment on avait le
Watcher ou Watou on avait Eternity mais
même eux c'était flou leur utilité et
leur raison d'être dans l'univers
Galactus a été créé pour être un vilain
un vilain avec les capacités d'un Dieu
et cela s'arrête là cependant les années
passants le monde de Marvel doit évoluer
et ces personnages également si le comic
262 des Quatre Fantastiques a fait
polémique pour certains c'est parce que
John bene l'écrivain en charge du comic
a tenté de justifier et neutraliser les
génocides planétaires de Galactus mais
malheureusement avec très peu de
véritaable justification puisque je vous
le rappelle Reid affirme que Galactus
doit avoir un rôle que l'on ne comprend
pas puis Eternity par la suite
intervient pour nous dire la même chose
si l'histoire de Galactus est
foncièrement compliquée c'est parce que
comme beaucoup d'autres il est une
innovation un renouveau un essai pour le
monde des comics et dans la symbolique
ce n'est pas un hasard si l'Origin story
de Galactus nous précise qu'il provient
de l'univers précédent c'est parce qu'il
est comme un aïul pour les êtres
cosmiques qui sont apparus petit à petit
par la suite et sa seule différence ce
qui nous permet un temps soit peu de
nous raccrocher au personnage c'est
qu'il est à la base un humain au final
ce qui est réellement impactant avec
Galactus et ce qui leur rend sans égal
bah c'est l'incompréhension qu'il dégage
au travers des comics ce qui traduit du
coup complètement son écriture au fil
des années il n'est que paradoxe il est
le début et la fin il est un être
cosmique et un humain il est à la fois
la mort et ce qui va permettre à la vie
de perpétuer Galactus n'est pas commun
il n'est pas banal il est complètement
différent de ce que nous avons
l'habitude de voir et je pense qu'il est
là le message Stanley et Jack Kirby
voulaient proposer du changement et
c'est pourquoi Galactus a plu et marqué
les esprits et malgré les années ce
trait est resté inchangé et c'est
pourquoi comme tout ce que je vous
raconte depuis le début de cette vidéo
Galactus est si
unique merci à tous d'avoir suivi ce
nouvel épisode et franchement c'est un
achievement d'avoir pu vous parler après
docteur Doom d'un autre Mastodon de
l'univers Marvel bon nous avons laissé
de côté pas mal de comics liés au
dévoreur de monde on aurait pu
développer d'autres points aussi qui
sont très intéressants comme les héros
de Galactus néanmoins je n'avais pas
envie que la vidéo soit encore une fois
beaucoup trop longue et surtout j'estime
que ce dont nous avons parlé permet
largement de comprendre l'unicité de
Galactus si la vidéo vous a plu vous
savez quoi faire n'hésitez pas non plus
à partager vos ressentis en commentaire
et puis n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
pour ne pas louper les prochaines
histoires sur ce c'était argoroc allez
ciao tout le
[Musique]
monde